bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 22
novembre dernier journal de la rédaction
pour cette semaine le tour de
l'actualité locale en 26 minutes voici
les titres le projet carré privé ouest
abandonné il devait relancer Skywest à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux le centre
commercial se cherche donc un nouvel
avenir il va falloir tout revoir début
de la 29ème campagne d'hiver des Restos
ce lundi 130 millions de repas
distribués l'an dernier à travers la
France nous verrons comment se prépare
l'association alors que la pauvreté
progresse annoncer fondateur des
éditions Rue du Monde avoisin le
bretonneuse a eu illustrateur ce sont
les invités du jour ils nous parlerons
des nouveautés de leur catalogue et du
Salon du livre et de la jeunesse de
Montreuil qui s'ouvre le 27 novembre
auparavant à l'image du jour c'est à la
station d'épuration à carré de réunion
basée sur la plaine de Versailles elle
fait peau neuve le syndicat mixte
d'assainissement de la région ouest de
Versailles a lancé un grand chantier de
rénovation d'agrandissement à terme la
station pourrait traiter les eaux usées
de tous les habitants de la plaine soit
près de 350 000 personnes ce chantier
n'est pas évidente à proximité avec le
château de Versailles a obligé les
constructeurs et les architectes à se
fondre dans le paysage faute d'avoir les
autorisations de construire
il fallait disparaître dans le terrain
c'est ce que nous avons fait les
toitures du des bâtiments qui sont en
train de se mettre en place à l'heure
actuelle ne dépasse pas le niveau des
voiries
qui desservent cette station donc la
station est complètement est
complètement enterrée les toitures qui
sont en train de se construire et de se
poser sur le premier bâtiment devant
lequel nous sommes ils sont des toitures
végétalisées donc cette station sera
complètement bien intégrée au site et ne
défigura en aucune façon le côté disons
un peu prestigieux dans lequel nous
sommes installés
la 29e campagne des Restos du Coeur qui
va donc s'ouvrir lundi avec plus que
jamais la volonté et de donner un chacun
un coup de pouce pour passer l'hiver
nous sommes en ligne avec le responsable
communication des Restos du Coeur Henri
FAL bonjour à vous
merci d'être en ligne vous êtes en train
de faire les de réaliser les derniers
préparatifs pardon de cette campagne
d'hiver est-ce que vous vous attendez à
une campagne difficile aujourd'hui
alors apparemment excusez-nous Henri FAL
on a une difficulté de communication de
liaison avec vous on va réessayer au
cours de ce journal de pouvoir discuter
échanger avec vous alors que va s'ouvrir
cette nouvelle campagne des Restos du
cœur on va pour l'instant continuer ce
journal en parlant et économique carré
privé ouest je vous le disais en titre
c'est terminé avant même d'avoir
commencé les promoteurs kodika Merson
promettait de relooker et l'espace
commercial Skywest à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux surtout de lui
donner un nouveau départ le transformant
en lieu de shopping dédié aux marques de
luxe seulement le Paris est raté les
explications
carré privé Ouest à Montigny c'est
terminé il n'y aura pas de boutique de
luxe à prix cassés en des termes plus
policés les deux investisseurs Cody qui
amerson évoquent dans un communiqué un
projet ajourné en raison de deux recours
sans en dire plus le maire lui se montre
plus prolixe il y a deux raisons
principales la première raison c'est que
il y avait une clause de non-concurrence
entre le projet le projet entre le
centre qui existe aujourd'hui sur
l'expérien à côté de Disney et donc il y
avait une clause d'encogurance dans un
rayon de 100 km et cette clause au
départ les investisseurs se faisaient
fort de la faire sauter aujourd'hui ils
n'y sont pas arrivés ça c'est la
première raison la deuxième raison c'est
qu'il y a eu aussi des recours contre
contre ce projet alors c'est vrai que ça
retarde aussi les éléments les
investisseurs évoquent aussi la volonté
de donner une nouvelle orientation au
centre commercial Skywest il réaffirme
toujours vouloir créer un pôle
commercial régional fort grâce à une
meilleure intégration des centres espace
Saint-Quentin et Skywest il va falloir
aussi que son travail entre les liaisons
entre les deux centres puisque les deux
centres devront faire plus qu'un dans le
projet tel qu'il est prévu par les
investisseurs pour le monde nous sommes
dans des esquisses et puis vous savez
très bien c'est un projet qui est privé
certes les liaisons se feront par les
passagers publics mais moi j'ai tout
confiance dans ces investisseurs vous
savez racheter un centre comme Skywest
ce n'est pas donné et aujourd'hui ça ne
court pas les rues ça c'est la première
chose et la deuxième c'est que des cas
même dans une situation géographique
intéressante en termes de géographie
justement à quelques kilomètres de
Montigny il y a Les Clayes-sous-Bois et
un projet similaire d'outelette de luxe
qui va lui bien voir le jour où one
nation Paris ouvre le 4 décembre avec 80
boutiques et pour eux l'abandon du
projet de Montigny ce n'est pas une
surprise ça fait déjà quelques temps
qu'on voit bien sur le sur le terrain
nos commercialisateurs se rendent compte
sur le terrain que le projet de Skywest
recrovection de Skywest en outlet luxe
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour nous sommes
partis en premier après on a bien
compris la volonté des personnes et de
Codic de tenter de redonner souffle à
Skywest qui qui effectivement éprouvé
quelques quelques difficultés en même
temps il y a des il y a des fondamentaux
dans la outlet de luxe en terme
d'environnement en terme d'indépendance
par rapport au Mas market aux
hypermarchés etc qui n'était pas
présents tout simplement à Skywest pour
Skywest c'est encore un coup dur au
prémisses du centre en 2003 son
orientation était tournée vers les
loisirs ils devaient s'appeler la fiesta
quelques mois plus tard changement de
cap la fiesta devient Skywest avec
toutes les difficultés que l'on connaît
pour exister en 2011 un seul
gestionnaire pour Skywest et espace
Saint-Quentin le groupe amerson avec ce
projet de carré privé ouest qui ne verra
finalement pas le jour ce sera donc la
quatrième variation pour le centre
commercial un tempo qui met du temps à
se trouver
et qu'attendent à présent les clients de
ce centre commercial Skywest comment
voit-il l'avenir comment l'imagine-t-il
voici quelques réponses au micro de
Jonathan Willeman
des boutiques peut-être pas de luxe des
boutiques plus abordables normal comme
ce qui était là mais maintenant je sais
pas ça reste à voir je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont mettre peut-être remettre
déjà des restaurants remettre le
chauffage aussi ça serait sympa
après bah je sais pas mettre quelque
chose de bien quoi
mais peut-être aussi des magasins les
plus activités pour les jeunes je sais
pas bowling déjà ils l'ont fermé c'est
dommage parce que sinon ici à 50 ans on
avait pas d'autres donc voilà
il va faire mes définitivement
il y avait un Gaumont dans l'ancien
centre il fonctionnait très bien et là
le fessier fonctionne Virgin a fermé
pour cessation de paiement donc je suis
même pas comment il fait pour survivre
par rapport aux charges par rapport au
bénéfices qui sont dégagés donc à mon
avis ça va pas durer longtemps donc on
va voir ce qui serait vraiment
à s'amuser parce que en fait le soir ici
il y a rien les bars il ferme à 23h
grand maximum encore c'est que le
vendredi soir alors que si on est dans
une ville étudiante et en fait quand on
est étudiant on va directement à Paris
parce qu'ici il se passe rien voilà donc
faut ouvrir des barres à mon avis ça va
finir en bureau mais sinon bah je sais
pas toute façon il y a pas grand chose
donc à mon avis ça va finir au bureau et
on en revient à cette formation cette
campagne des Restos du cœur qui va donc
s'ouvrir Henry Fall vous êtes donc en
ligne avec nous responsable
communication pour les restos du cœur
des Yvelines et je vous demandais tout à
l'heure comment vous appréhendiez cette
cette campagne justement qui va débuter
probablement toujours autant de monde
voir plus mais il est encore beaucoup
trop tôt pour savoir si
il y aura plus d'inscription ou moins
d'inscription c'est à dire qu'on sait
pas à l'heure actuelle si c'est les gens
qui s'inscrivent plus vite ou si c'est
il y a une augmentation donc il faut
attendre pour avoir des résultats disons
fin décembre mi-janvier combien de repas
ont été distribués dans le département
l'an dernier
l'année dernière donc c'était la
campagne d'hiver on a distribué un peu
plus d'un million de repas là ce sont
les préparatifs la campagne d'hiver 2013
va s'ouvrir lundi comment cela se passe
actuellement sur le terrain les
bénévoles sont en train d'approvisionner
les différents centres
les bénévoles sont en train de
recueillir les informations sur des
bénéficiaires et de faire des
inscriptions et ensuite tout ce qui est
logistique c'est le branle-bas de combat
donc sur l'entrepôt on a reçu de quoi
fournir les centres nos 26 ans de
distribution pour à peu près 3 semaines
et on fonctionne en flux tendu donc on
n'a jamais plus de 15 jours 3 semaines
de stock c'est tout pour terminer on va
juste rappeler que les Restos du coeur
c'est également une association qui
intervient pour l'insertion sociale
l'insertion économique des plus démunis
absolument on a deux chantiers d'ins un
plaisir un à Aubergenville où ils font
de la réparation
d'ordinateurs et on a 24 salariés par an
dans chacun des chacun de ces centres ou
on essaye de le remettre le pied à
l'étrier et c'est un métier assez
difficile merci d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous alors que vous êtes en plein
en préparatif avec cette campagne qui va
s'ouvrir lundi pour se terminer en mars
cette campagne de distribution
alimentaire d'hiver nous aurons bien sûr
à l'occasion d'y revenir au cours de nos
prochaines éditions retour à présent sur
le mouvement des agriculteurs et hier
jeudi pour vous dire que le blocage des
axes routiers qui menaient à la capitale
organisée par la Fédération
Départementale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles d'Île-de-France
et la section régionale il y a des
jeunes agriculteurs à provoqué la colère
du gouvernement le ministre de
l'Agriculture Stéphane Le Foll n’entend
pas à revenir sur les choix précédentes
et il a redit hier soir encore même si
la mobilisation a été fortement suivie
vous avez pu le suivre hier sur notre
antenne reportage en replay a consulté
sur notre site internet dès à présent la
ministre de la Justice c'est Christiane
Taubira à Versailles cette semaine alors
que l'Union Syndicale des Magistrats
dénonce son bilan quel juge est limité
l'échange s'est déroulée avec les
conseils des prud'hommes et les
juridictions sociales claire Cambier
était sur place
la ministre de la Justice Christine
Taubira s'est rendue aujourd'hui à la
cour d'appel de Versailles elle y a
rencontré les professionnels du secteur
pour parler des juridictions du 21e
siècle le bâtonnier de Versailles en a
profité pour lui parler de la
juridictionnelle on se souvient qu'il
manifestait encore au début du mois ça
craintes une baisse du budget de l'État
la Garde des Sceaux a cherché à le
rassurer le pas de décision hâtives qui
serait effectivement regrettable c'était
le cas notamment lorsqu'on a imaginé
baissé l'indemnité il y a quelques mois
aujourd'hui tout cela est mis de côté et
nous ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
nous puissions discuter de l'avenir de
la juridictionnelle de sa composante des
budgets de la participation par exemple
de budget extérieur à l'état il faut que
tout ça soit discuté et je crois que ce
sera fait dans l'année
2014-2015 autre point évoqué le
fonctionnement des conseils des
prud'hommes et des juridictions sociales
ainsi que la justice des mineurs
principales problèmes des délais trop
longs
il faut corriger l'accumulation de
mission qui disperse les énergies les
intelligences le temps les moyens il
faut réorganiser de même pour les
mesures immédiates j'ai introduit dans
le projet de loi d'habilitation toute
une série de mesures de simplification
qui vont alléger clarifier simplifier et
donc permettre un travail plus facile en
fin d'après-midi des manifestants contre
le mariage pour tous l'attendait mais le
passage de la Garde des Sceaux ministres
la plus protégée du gouvernement n'a pas
été perturbé
et puisque l'on parle justice sachez
qu'un jeune homme de 20 ans a été
condamné à huit mois de prison ferme
hier jeudi au tribunal de Versailles il
lui est reproché et des violences envers
les forces de l'ordre lors des émeutes à
trappe en juillet des émeutes
consécutives vous le savez au contrôle
d'identité par la police et d'une femme
portant un voile intégral la campagne
des municipales la plaisir avec une
alliance entre le PS Europe Écologie Les
Verts le modem et l'association
citoyenne agir pour plaisir les
différentes formations ce sont entendues
autour d'une liste commune menée par le
socialiste Bernard Ansart le PRG
génération écologiste soutiennent
l'initiative on retiendra que les
militants plaisirs rois du mouvement
démocratant donc refusé de se rapprocher
de l'UDI malgré les choix au niveau
national de Jean-Louis Borloo et de
François Bayrou et nous avons vu il y a
un instant les différentes formations
lors d'un point presse commun programme
qui sera dévoilé par Bernard Ransart
dans les prochaines semaines
de son côté Jean-Frédéric Poisson député
de la dixième circonscription des
Yvelines a donc succédé à Christine
Boutin cette semaine à la tête du Parti
Chrétien Démocrate plébiscite des
militants avec plus de 75% des suffrages
lors du vote interne j'en Frédéric
poisson à qui nous avons demandé comment
aller évoluer au cours des prochains
mois les relations avec l'UMP le
partenaire privilégié du Parti Chrétien
Démocrate
et puis nous sommes à la fois associés à
les QP sans être marié ça veut dire que
nous sommes capables d'avoir beaucoup de
chances coopération localement dans les
territoires ou à l'Assemblée nationale
ou dans les chambres du Parlement et
partout simplement il y a des choses qui
sont chères au cas de nous tenons et
effectivement nous voulons qu'elle soit
prise en compte donc associés à Marion
ça veut dire que la majorité du temps
nous travaillons ensemble sans toutefois
être complètement liés à des solublement
nous avons aujourd'hui
l'université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines qui peut souffler son président
a obtenu du ministère une rallonge
budgétaire de 4 millions d'euros le
montant du déficit actuel un plan de
réduction des dépenses drastiques va en
revanche mettre en place pour 2014 elle
est syndicat reste vigilant
Jean-Luc Veyssière était resté
silencieux ces derniers jours le
président de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin est sorti de sa réserve ce
mercredi pour annoncer que le ministère
avait accordé une rallonge de 4 millions
d'euros le montant du déficit de l'UVSQ
j'aurais souhaité avoir un peu plus j'ai
pu obtenir donc de la souplesse qui
permet à l'université d'Honoré donc des
factures au petit fournisseurs que on
aurait de nouveaux engagements
contractuels avec des partenaires
notamment étrangers des partenaires de
recherche et également des engagements
pour permettre de faire fonctionner les
formations des signes afin de l'année
une rallonge qui s'a sortie d'un plan de
retour à l'équilibre en trois ans à
hauteur de 7 millions d'euros cela va
commencer dès 2014 avec une réduction de
dépenses de 4 millions dont 3 millions
rien que pour la masse salariale il y a
pas de licenciement donc ça c'était un
objectif pour moi important de pas
licencier des contractuel de ne pas les
fragiliser comment s'y protons donc on a
du gel d'emploi nous avons eu
21 emplois dans le cadre du plan de la
ministre en 2013 nous avons que 6
emplois ensuite donc on restreint les
recrutements si on licencie pas par
contre on limite les recrutements donc
en restructure au niveau des services
aussi au niveau des services des
directions université donc ça c'est pas
le volet formation il va donc falloir se
serrer la ceinture les masters ne
seraient pas concernés certains parcours
dans les licences seraient eux
restreints mais d'où vient ce déficit le
syndicat sneu peut dénonce les
partenariats publics privés trop coûteux
pour l'université signé notamment pour
la construction de l'UFR des Sciences à
Montigny le syndicat demande une
commission d'enquête pour réétudier ces
contrats la prochaine étape c'est le
vote du budget 2014 début décembre
les syndicats justement leur réaction
celle de Jérôme doveau déjà il est
membre du SNESS sup sur ce plateau en
début de semaine il nous expliquait que
les difficultés de fonctionnement se
faisaient déjà ressentir sur le terrain
depuis plusieurs mois
la situation la difficulté ce sont déjà
sentir depuis plusieurs mois il faut
être clair ça se traduit comment tout
simplement 70% des postes qui devaient
être ouverts en 2013 ont été gelés donc
supprimés 500.000 euros a été demandé
d'économies aux UFR sur cette formation
et de recherche donc des facteurs nous
avons déjà
soit fermé des travaux des des des TD
soit il y a des il y a des filières qui
sont déjà en difficulté nous n'avons pas
nous n'avions VSQ été avait été reconnu
comme étant une fac
je dirais à la pointe sur le plan
réussite licence bon bah moi je dirige
un département dans l'UEFA sciences
sociales c'est clair les effets je n'ai
pas ouvert de tuto cette année depuis la
rentrée l'université en faillite c'est
possible alors c'est vrai que
formellement l'université est autonome
si elle ne peut plus payée elle ne peut
payer pour autant et c'est bien ça le
jeu dupe des responsabilités compétences
élargies c'est le ministère qui nous
finance ça a été un leurre de croire que
en montant des fondations et tout un tas
de d'opérations de communication nous
allions ramener des nouvelles sources de
financement non je reçois deux invités à
présent pour la suite du 7 8 l'actu de
cette édition à l'insert bonjour à tous
les deux bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau à l'insert auteur et fondateur
de Rue du Monde maison d'édition
jeunesse basée à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
et depuis 1996 la devise de cette maison
d'édition les oiseaux ont des ailes les
enfants ont des livres et à eux
illustrateurs vous travaillez
régulièrement avec la maison d'édition
rue du monde vous avez réalisé une
trentaine de livres pour rue du monde
Grand Prix de l'illustration en 2011
également pour Mandela multicolore je
vais vous emprunter l'ouvrage parce que
je sais que vous êtes venu avec voir
comme ça le présenter à la caméra cet
ouvrage vous avez eu donc le Grand Prix
de l'illustration en 2011 pour ce livre
on va parler de l'actualité de la maison
rue du monde et puis tout d'abord ce
festival du livre jeunesse et de la
presse jeunesse 2013 qui va s'ouvrir à
Montreuil le 27 novembre prochain avec
vos auteurs vos illustrateurs qui seront
présents ce salon pour votre maison
d'édition c'est un moment privilégié
particulier pour exister au milieu de
toutes les autres maisons et elles sont
nombreuses d'édition
on est à travers le pays de très
nombreux salons du livre représentent
toute l'année mais là c'est vrai c'est
le c'est le point d'orgue 150 200000
visiteurs et notre petite maison donne
je dirais tous les coups de ce qu'elle
est dans cette manifestation et là on se
régale rencontrer des milliers d'enfants
de passionnés de parents il y a beaucoup
d'amateurs de livres jeunesse beaucoup
de professionnels bien sûr enseignants
bibliothécaire qui viennent les quatre
coins du pays Montreuil devient à ce
moment-là la capitale du livre jeunesse
donc il y a toute notre place oui et
vous allez présenter forcément vos
nouveautés on va en évoquer quelques
unes dans un instant déjà on précise
aussi que vous serez présent sur
plusieurs débats lors du salon avec des
thématiques comme comment transmettre la
poésie peut-on repenser le monde avec
les enfants qu'est-ce qui donne des
ailes aux images des albums également
alors justement vous avez vu je vais
vous poser la question comment
donne-t-on des ailes aux images
lorsque vous travaillez en tant
qu'illustrateur pour capter l'attention
des enfants je pense que je travaille
surtout pour moi au départ parce que je
pense qu'un livre de jeunesse il faut
qu'il plaise avant tout l'illustrateur
que ce soit moi qui soit le juge du
créateur de ça et je après je vérifie
qu'il plaît aux enfants c'est je fais
souvent des rencontres de classe et tout
ça et j'aime bien vérifier ce phénomène
que ça marche avec eux mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas en face de moi une cible quand
je fais le dessin je les vois pas avec
des ailes en face mais moi j'ai besoin
d'avoir des ailes pour le faire et on
aperçoit le livre que vous venez
d'illustrer c'est l'une des nouveautés
de rue du monde en cette fin d'année on
va voir quelques images aussi à l'écran
des illustrations que vous avez signé le
texte est d'Alain CR c'est un livre
cette histoire d'un enfant qui a tout
oublié qui va voyager au cœur de ce
qu'ils font de notre humanité c'est de
cette façon que l'enfant qui savait lire
les animaux et présenter vous pouvez
nous en dire plus à l'insert
me disant que je me suis blessé porter
par le travail de zahu c'est un livre
qui a une drôle d'histoire d'habitude
c'est le texte qui préexiste
illustrateur qui travaille à partir du
texte là on a connu avec zu parce que
nous sommes deux aventuriers depuis
longue date de ce genre de
découverte et de pratique et voilà j'ai
je me suis laissé porter par des
centaines d'animaux qu'il avait dessiné
et j'ai fait émerger une histoire et
j'ai senti que cette histoire-là devait
naître et j'ai écrit donc l'histoire
d'un enfant qui va découvrir qu'il est
son humanité qu'il est tenu main
différent des animaux à travers son
regard sur le monde animal je pense
qu'on a beaucoup à apprendre de la
nature du monde animal et j'avais envie
de dire aux enfants et aux adultes qui
aimeront ce livre aussi voilà on peut
apprendre la patience l'observation
l'obstination on peut apprendre à se
dissimuler on peut
apprendre aussi à être plus fort que ce
qu'on est d'habitude se dépasser
plus là le personnage le vit de d'image
en images de rencontres animales
rencontres animales pour devenir en fin
de compte l'humain qui va être plus tard
donc une très forte aventure un vrai
bonheur que d'imaginer l'adolescence la
reconstruction aussi beaucoup de
symboles dans ce livre sa propre liberté
comment on se construit jamais seul
toujours avec les autres en l'occurrence
le monde naturel ici mais et comment
effectivement on passe des étapes
comment la vie nous propose des épreuves
il faut affronter pour devenir soi-même
je pense que c'était un livre
qui donne des ailes justement pour oser
grandir puis pour aimer les belles
choses aussi et ça c'est très important
pour nous à l'heure un petit peu et du
fast-food et du acheter jeté dans la
consommation que les enfants possèdent
un petit trésor de papier un petit
chef-d'oeuvre graphique comme ça me
semble important ils ont besoin de
repères clairs aussi dans le bon goût je
dirais et vous avez travaillé cette
histoire vous l'avez dit à partir des
illustrations directement travail un
petit peu particulier on va s'intéresser
justement à ces illustrations qu'on
aperçoit et depuis tout à l'heure à
l'antenne vous êtes allés dans les parcs
animaliers pour les crocs
une série de croquis de dessin que
j'avais fait au Kenya il y a déjà un bon
bail une bonne vingtaine d'années quand
même parce que j'ai été me promener dans
les parcs de là-bas donc j'avais pas mal
dessiné pendant et après et puis je me
suis dit bon j'ai pas comme j'aime pas
beaucoup travailler d'après des photos
ça me ça me fait un effet de de ça
s'arrêter la photo quoi je sais pas ce
qui est à côté et j'aime bien les voir
les livrets animaux en soi donc j'ai été
à Beauval entre autres qui est très beau
zoo où il y a justement un panda
et les autres mais j'ai pu redessiner de
tous ceux qui me manquaient quoi tous
ceux que j'avais pas en réserve dans ma
boîte mentale mais à chaque fois en
fonction des ouvrages vous avez des
différentes aussi mais vous avez déjà
travaillé ensemble je le reprécise aussi
avec à l'insert sur une cuisine grande
comme le monde
que ce qui m'intéresse c'est de trouver
une écriture qui soit propre à ce livre
là spécialement quand on lui a demandé
là celui-là il y a aucun rapport de
d'écriture et je trouve ça intéressant
de de lui donner une identité comme ça
je
pense que je sais pas si je vais arriver
à trouver autre chose pour le prochain
ça reste toujours une question mais ça
dépend tellement du thème que il y a pas
il y a pas une préméditation là-dessus
premier titre en 1967 publié à 24 ans
comment on entretient cet amour du
dessin
on a une vie de descente que j'ai
travaillé toute ma vie dans le dessin
pour une bonne vingtaine d'années dans
la pub au travers des roches des
milliers de dessins ce qui ce qui m'a
libéré de la feuille blanche feuille
blanche il peut aller au panier assez
facilement c'est pas le problème mais de
d'en faire comme ça des stocks ça m'a
permis de d'avoir une perception de ce
qui vous de ce qui est rapide de ce qui
est un événement
je me suis posé la question est-ce que
c'est plus intéressant de travailler
plus lentement et non en fait je préfère
faire plusieurs fois le même dessin et
choisir celui que celui que je préfère
dire que la vitesse je me suis dit c'est
finalement c'est pas handicap c'est
plutôt un avantage ça me permet de
devoir plusieurs fois la même chose le
dessiner recommencer ma fenêtre puis
après je choisis qu'est-ce qui est bien
qu'est-ce qui est pas bien voilà
l'enfant qui savait lire les animaux à
partir de 7 ans avec vos illustrations
il nous reste assez peu de temps pour
cet entretien le temps passe très vite
j'aimerais tout de même qu'on aborde
l'autre actualité de la maison d'édition
c'est la publication de cet ouvrage
aussi et avec Tango nous voilà trois
pourquoi cet ouvrage parce qu'il fait
écho un débat de société ce sont deux
manchots de mal qui finalement voit la
naissance d'un œuf d'un bébé manchot et
qui vont élever ce petit manchot voilà
et donc c'est une histoire vraie qui a
eu lieu dans un zoo aux autres New York
et voilà c'est un livre qui est sorti
aux États-Unis il y a quelques années et
voilà nous avons souhaité nous le le
publier
pour dire aux enfants il faut vivre
comme cela et serait bien stupide de
s'inspirer du monde animal mais pour
nous donner à penser dans ces débats qui
ont eu lieu cette année
posons-nous un petit peu en famille
pourquoi pas autour de deux ce livre là
et réfléchissons un peu à ce qu'est la
vie et voilà de la vocation du livre
jeunesse c'est en tout cas la vocation
que vous lui prêtez et celle que vous
voulez imposer
une époque où le livre jeunesse mettait
un peu les enfants à l'abri du monde et
nous on se bat pour un livre jeunesse
qui permet de s'interroger sur le monde
en famille et les enfants ont besoin de
se construire des repères c'est mieux de
le faire en discutant ensemble que de
d'asseoir les enfants devant la
télévision excusez-moi mais mais c'est
bien de faire avec eux et échanger
autour de leur livre je crois qu'il y a
rien de meilleur pour bien grandir c'est
une approche que vous partagez oui tout
à fait je pense que le le livre de
jeunesse est un lien
avec les adultes entre les enfants les
adultes ce que ce soit des instits tous
ou des parents des adultes en tout cas
je vois très bien que quand je dédicace
des bouquins que c'est souvent les
adultes qui achètent le livre et qu'il
parce qu'il aime eux je pense que eux
ils vont me faire passer à l'enfant
c'est pas un objet de consommation ils
vont pas lui dire dans ta chambre
tranquillement ils vont ils vont le lire
avec lui et je reprécise aussi la sortie
de cette autre ouvrage on n'aura pas le
temps de développer plus mais je vous le
recommande aussi et si on redessinait le
monde se sont de très belles
illustrations plein de sur des
planisphères par Nathalie Novy avec des
textes de Daniel Picouly merci à tous
les deux d'être venu sur ce plateau
c'est toujours trop court lorsqu'on
parle de vos ouvrages à chaque fois
merci encore on vous a sans doute donné
quelques idées quelques idées pour les
Père Noël qui nous écoutent et n'oubliez
pas aussi un salon du livre pour
rencontrer à Montreuil les auteurs les
illustrateurs de cette maison d'édition
le journal revient lundi on est très
pris par le temps si vous nous suivez en
direct vous avez rendez-vous avec le 7 8
weekend des Catherine zolato pour vous
sortir